quelques minutes avant le coup d'envoi
du match c'est un président tout sourire
qui salue les joueurs de Nantes et
Toulouse dans le couloir menant au
terrain et non sur la pelouse comme le
veut parfois la couture des aménagements
qui montrent la fébrilité du
gouvernement 3000 policiers et gendarmes
avaient été mobilisés pour la soirée un
dispositif deux fois plus important que
celui pour la finale de la Ligue des
Champions en mai dernier il voulait
éviter d'éventuelles siffler et les
cartons rouges distribués par les
syndicats peu nombreux hier soir en
tribune l'intersyndcale avait appelé une
action symbolique à la 40e minute en
référence au 49.3 oui un carton rouge
c'est symbolique c'était un match de
foot mais c'était pas l'idée dans la
sève pour la CFDT en tout cas de
perturber un événement sportif parce
qu'encore une fois on a besoin de ça
dans nos dans nos vies les uns et les
autres on a besoin des maisons sportives
d'événements culturels des cartons
rouges confisqués par les portiers seuls
les spectateurs qui sont arrivés après
20h ont pu entrer avec résultat dans les
tribunes peu de cartons rouges levés
Président on a un président de la
République qui fait signer des arrêtés
par les préfets pour dire qu'il faut pas
des casseroles qui émanent une bagarre
contre les sifflets contre les cartons
rouges enfin qui salut les joueurs dans
les vestiaires sans qu'on voit son image
à l'affiche tout ça est quand même ça
devrait entrer dans le business bouche
du ridicule
la plupart ont fini au fond des
poubelles le seul qui a commencé en 2017
à descendre sur la pelouse parce que
c'est un fan de foot allez salut les
joueurs c'est lui alors maintenant le
critique parce qu'il va pas descendre
juste vous dites il a pu s'allumer le
tunnel avant l'entrée avant l'entrée des
joueurs ça fait 85 ans que la tradition
veut que le Président de la République
aille saluer les équipes sur la pelouse
il ne l'a pas fait il a salué dans les
vestiaires les équipes donc
courageux mais pas téméraire
30 secondes du match qui s'est déroulé
correctement il y a pas eu de problème à
la fin du match 49e minute que les gens
attendaient ce soir
quelques timides sifflets maintenant il
nous faut un grand satiriste dans ce
pays il nous faut les Guignols de l'Info
faites les Guignols de l'info et vous
allez retrouver un public là-dessus
parce que tout ça vous savez c'est beau
marché soit on en pleure soit on en fait
la chef de fil des députés RNC s'est
exprimé dans un entretien ou parisien
selon elle Emmanuel Macron considère que
l'usure est une stratégie mais ce n'est
pas tenable Elisabeth borne voulu parler
on est face à du vide il y a de l'écho
elle ne prend la parole que pour
annoncer des renoncements d'éventuels
projets ça fait 600 milliards d'euros de
dettes pendant son premier mandat alors
justement en parlant finance on rappelle
que la note que l'agence Fitch a abaissé
la note de la France de AA+ à AA moins
s'il n'y a pas de retrait de cette
réforme il y aura une défiance profonde
dans le pays le gouvernement ne pourra
plus réformer et c'est d'ailleurs ce que
dit l'agence speech qui vient de
dégrader la note de la France pour cette
raison là plus de 300 rassemblements
sont prévus dans toute la France demain
et cent mille personnes sont attendues
pour la manifestation à Paris ça
confirme que cette réforme ne sert
vraiment à rien parce que le seul
argument pour défendre cette réforme
violente c'était de dire c'est pour
rassurer les marchés financiers et on
voit au contraire que ça conduit à une
dégradation de la note de la France
alors ce sera sans conteste un 1er mai
sous haute tension avec 500 à 650 000
manifestants attendus partout en France
c'est 5 à 6 fois plus que l'année
dernière on voit bien que le l'objectif
ce matin c'est de réussir le premier mai
et ce qu'on a comme retour c'est que le
1er mai va être un des plus gros
premiers mai sur la question sociale de
ces 30 ou 40 dernières années je
m'attends effectivement un mouvement
possiblement suivi mais il est un
certain nombre de pronostics qui parfois
ne sont pas confirmés ces dernières
semaines la CFD ne sera ni dans
l'activisme ni dans les actions coup de
poing ni dans le fait d'emmener les
travailleurs dans le mur en leur faisant
croire qu'on pourrait faire en sorte que
le Président de la République a progué
ses lois la retire trois individus à
moto stationne et semble faire le guet
devant la bijouterie Bulgarie sur la
séquence suivante on les voit démarrer
leur moto et s'enfuir
brassard orange au bras juché sur des
motos les trois hommes se seraient fait
passer pour des policiers avant de
blesser à la tête le vigile de la
boutique que l'on voit ici évacuer par
les secours président américain est
revenu également sur son âge 80 ans pour
lequel il est critiqué ils ont dit que
j'étais vieux moi je dis que je suis
expérimenté